herr alt ist bei uns den ich gerne
fragen würde weil er den einsatz dort
auch der der bundeswehr geleitet hat wie
läuft das ab erhalten wenn man wenn man
wenn so ein anruf kommt wo waren sie und
dann ging es ruckzuck nach kabul ja also
erst der anruf kam war ich zu hause auf
einer familienfeier
haben ganz normal
geburtstag nachgefeiert und dann gegen
die telefonate ein also ein titel von
hat jagte das andere wir haben dafür
also kräfte ja auch in deutschland
bereit die dafür auf abruf stehen und
dann läuft im endeffekt wieso nadja
schweizer uhrwerk ab also die kräfte
werden aktiviert wir fahren in die
standort rhein wir bereiten uns vor wir
trennen uns von den familien und dann
waren wir im endeffekt auf den
einsatzbefehl und dann fliegen wir
wollen so weit fliegen sie rein nach
kabul sie wissen nicht was sie dort
erwartet was haben sie vorgefunden waren
wie muss man sich so eine situation
vorstellen es gab ja auch viel kritik
wie kann es sein dass die dass die
bundeswehr davon überrascht wird wie die
zustände dort sind wie kann es sein dass
man da nur mit sieben leuten zum teil in
seinem flieger wieder rausfliegt aus
kabul erklären sie uns einfach denn das
relativ simpel das eine bild was wir
gesehen haben dass stürmen der des
flugplatzes führt dazu dass sie nicht
landen können also sind menschen und
material auf denen auf denen sozusagen
landebahn und sie müssen erstmal
sicherheit wiederherstellen gleichzeitig
sind viele nationen kommen rein mit
ihnen und sie müssen auch diese
koordinieren das heißt jetzt beginnt als
alles wie ein wettlauf mit der ist in
diesem jahr aus da müssen sie versuchen
und sie müssen erstmal rein sie müssen
erstmal füße auf dem boden kriegen auf
den grund um die evakuierung beginnen zu
können und das erklärt auch in diesem
chaos indem wir drin waren dass wir gar
nicht am anfang es muss nur unsere
kräfte erst rein bringen um auch
bestimmte systeme aufzubauen das braucht
zeit dafür brauchen sie kräfte und in
der phase war es dann nur möglich mit
den kräften die wir eingebracht haben
die die vor ort sozusagen flughafen
waren auszuführen das waren diese sieben
das waren angehörige der botschaft die
also am sonntag schon erfahrung der
botschaftsgelände dann dementsprechend
reingekommen sind und der gesamte
jan-hendrik fand ihn mit seinem thema
dann entschieden die gehen sofort raus
dass wir kräfte mit rausnehmen
5000 trabants am ende mehr als 5000
leute wird diese herausgeflogen haben
die amerikaner haben sehr viel mehr
leute raus gemacht warum waren es am
ende dann doch diese was diese
überschaubare zahl wie muss man sich das
vorstellen sie haben vor der sendung zu
mir gesagt das ist ein bisschen so als
würde man in einem stadion bei schalke
aus diesem riesen start und zwei drei
leute rauspicken und die genau die
musste erst mal finden ja dass das
problem ist relativ simpel anstellt muss
sich die vorstände sind alles die
gleichen eingängen und tore wo sie rein
und raus müssen das ist wie
fußballstadion spiel ist zu ende alle
gehen durch die gleichen tor aus jetzt
versuchten sie ganz gezielt leute zu
finden aber das machen sie ja nicht nur
alleine so eine andere nation auch das
heißt alle versuche nur begleichen
eingänge und ausgänge personal reine
fonds zu kriegen das ist also ein
wettlauf so und das hilft ihnen nichts
wenn sie in der tiefe des raumes
deutsche sehen ja oder deutschen
staatsbürger oder auch trotz kraft die
die ausgeflogen werden sollen oder die
sich auszeichnen als wären sie ist und
sie müssen dafür erst mal meinetwegen
neuseeländer niederländer ukraine und so
weiter auch mit reinbringen und das ist
das dilemma in den sie stellen also
immer sie müssen sie sozusagen an die
ihre leute ran kommen und dann müssen
sie selektieren ob es die richtigen sind
die ausfliegen und die ich sie haben
unglaubliche szenen geschildert sie
sagten da wurden kinder benutzt um in
den flughafen zu gelangen und dann
einfach weggeschmissen die kinder wurden
weggeschmissen ja das dass das ist das
ist wirklich so also wir haben in
bestimmten bereichen toren das gesehen
dass wirklich also männer versucht haben
durch kinder dienten entwendet worden
sind sich zugang zu verschaffen in der
hoffnung dass sie es jetzt geschafft
hätten und im inneren bereich des
flughafen zu sein das waren sie aber
noch nicht das heißt in ihrem glauben
waren sie so weit dass sie sagten die
kinder brauchen jetzt mehr haben sich
der kinder entledigt zum teil abgelegt
weggeworfen auch in abwasserkanäle
reingeschmissen usw so und dann haben
wir dementsprechend auch reagierten
haben alte uns auch um die kinder
gekümmert in zwei
fahrzeugen es gibt diesen satz von ihnen
wo sie sagten zu ihren leuten spricht
darüber und wenn ihr weinen müsst dann
weint euer kommandeur weint auch ja das
ist ein klares zitat formlos geld also
ich hab da männer und frauen gab wir
haben viel geredet das ganz wichtig um
einfach ein gespür für die situation zu
kriegen und sie merken dass es die
männer und frauen nicht nicht kalt lässt
also sie sind beschäftigt sie gucken
sozusagen in so tue ich sag mal so schön
die toten augen schauen sie also ganz
tief und die leute sind in sich
versunken die sitzen der sonne obwohl
sie im schatten sitzen können usw und da
sage ich okay was ist und dann habe ich
darüber gesprochen einfach redet
miteinander spricht darüber hier ist es
nicht ja versucht euch darauf zu
konzentrieren und wenn ihr weint weint
ihr ganz wichtig lasst die kerze der
menschlichkeit ist einerseits staaten
aber ich glaube dass das ein so extrem
situation extrem wichtig ist dass man
menschen